Canada is home to 10% of the world's
most top cited researchers,
many of whom are right here in Alberta.
I see the high caliber of AI talent here
every day at Amii
where our researchers,
staff and students
set out to do ambitious things.
The driving forces
for the current wave of AI
were pioneered right here in Canada,
so it's no wonder that
international talent
from around the world
want to come to Canada
to learn and study
under the best and brightest.
What's really exciting for me
is how Canada's three National AI Institues
work with industry partners.
From start ups to large industry,
we work with companies
to be able to help them
identify where AI can be
used in their business
in responsible and useful ways,
helping them
train their workforce
and continue to grow Canadian AI talent.
It's fantastic to watch industry
learn from our researchers
and our researchers learn from industry
about what their needs are
so we can turn fundamental research
into real world opportunity.
This is what excites me about
Canadian AI talent.
We're continuing to build the future
and we're just getting started.